it looks very impressive doesn't it yes
and it's very exciting and I found it
quite this is odd thing to say but I
found it quite touching because I
remember I remember when I was cast as
Loki for the very first time almost 10
years ago and Kevin Feige the president
of Marvel Studios called me into his
office to congrat to say congratulations
and then one of the first things servers
let me talk to you about Avengers and I
thought I just been cast in thought
right and he's told me the dream he had
to to build to build this a fleet of
films this Marvel Cinematic Universe
that was culminating in Avengers and
suddenly the marvel cinematic universes
has expanded to such an extraordinary
size that it can you know encompass and
encapsulate so many different characters
who people have taken to their hearts
and and followed and loved whether it's
all the people from the Captain America
films or the guardians of the galaxy or
you know it's become so peopled now I
was just it's just it's just so
impressive and I say that almost outside
it yeah and I feel so lucky to be a part
of it so that's why I found it exciting
hey everybody so if you guys didn't know
Tom Hiddleston has another movie that's
coming out the exact same weekend is
Black Panther what a coincidence that is
is actually the CG animated film so he's
only doing the voice for it it's called
early man but naturally he's doing the
interview rounds everyone's asking him
about Loki and infinity war in how he's
dealing with the culmination of
everything that he's been a part of so
time to start thinking about what's
going on with a Loki character during
these movies because I think he's been
on this arc ever since that first Thor
film where he just feels like this
complete outsider but turns out
Odin loved him this whole time like a
son he just been this Mobe teenager for
thousands of years and then just careful
for spoilers for Thor Ragnarok because I
have to talk about Loki during that film
it involves some Odin spoilers so here
we go
during Ragnarok when Odin dies you know
you sort of realized how he truly felt
about Loki like he always chuckled at
all of Loki's tricks of ocean as well I
left him right here my sons I've been
waiting for you
Loki left your magic quite a while to
break free from your spell trigger would
have been proud you see him standing
there reminiscing about his wife Frigga
how he's going to join her soon how he
loves both of his sons and it just
really at peace with what's going on
with his life at the moment so in that
moment you sort of see Loki and Thor
bond in a way that they haven't before
even though throughout the film they
sort of go back and forth like Loki
plays his tricks but Thor's wised up to
some of them so Loki has slowly become a
hero by the end of thor ragnarok my
people your savior is here it tells you
everything you need to know about the
character like yes he cares about ruling
but he really just wants the love of his
people in his family so when we heard
him talk about his arc during infinity
war about how he's actually going to be
team Thanos at the beginning of the film
it threw a lot of things into question
like Oh obviously he's pretending to be
team Thanos so that he can undermine him
from the inside if a tester
new baron no crevice where you cannot
fight you I wouldn't worry brother I
feel like everything's gonna work out
fine
[Music]
so that's how a nose gets the space gem
you see Loki holding the tesseract then
you seethe annos plopping the space gem
into the gauntlet so putting two and two
together he probably shows up at the end
of Ragnarok takes the tesseract from
Loki who gives it to him without putting
up a fight but if Loki is on this hero
arc then what is he going to do to try
and stop the nose and does he crawl into
Avengers 4 because I honestly think that
there might be some Loki related moment
during infinity war or maybe at the
beginning of Avengers 4 where he dies
but in doing so gives the Avengers one
of the upsets that they need to help win
the day so eventually the Avengers will
defeat Thanos but I think we all expect
them at the end of infinity war to be in
absolute shambles because Thanos needs
to assemble the gauntlet and in
everything that we've seen so far he has
maximum three of the gems so it actually
sounds like he heads into Avengers 4
without all six of them in the gauntlet
but however it goes down it definitely
feels like Loki will genuinely die and
that was you know that moment in Thor
Ragnarok were there doing the Matt Damon
play where they're redoing the events of
Thor to the dark world where Loki
pretended to sacrifice his life we might
actually see a version of that come to
pass only it'll be more real this time
no trick this time brother but I think
part of the beauty of the character is
that they always leave a little wiggle
room because Loki is the god of mischief
so even if it does seem like he
genuinely dies and Tom Hiddleston is
like you know I'll come back if they
call me to come back but I don't think
they're gonna call me to come back it'll
look like he is definitely dead so
obviously that doesn't address any of
the core Avengers that I think that'll
probably die but Tom Hiddleston talks
about that first Avengers film if you
didn't know he actually auditioned for
the role of Thor before he auditioned
for Loki you know at first Tom was on
for Thor trained he came in he was
ripped you know swinging the hammer
he did a tremendous job but he wasn't
Thor and the moment he came in and read
though it was the monkey you're my son I
wanted only to protect you from the
truth because I am the monster parents
tell their children about but you could
use imagine just what it would look like
if it had been the other way around and
then this is a little piece from the
original Avengers trailer you were made
to be ruled
in the end
[Music]
it would be every man for himself big
question for you guys Tom Hiddleston's
contract with Marple is up do you think
that he's going to sacrifice himself
like a true hero's death during this
next two Avengers films to help the
Avengers out and will he come back
after phase four just to put it into
context Chris Hemsworth is definitely
coming back for more Thor during phase
four so I think as long as he's around
there's always a chance that we see some
form of Loki even if it's a flashback or
it's just mine space Loki where he's
speaking to him in the way that Odin
speaks to him from beyond the grave
what were you the god of again even when
you had to I you'll see only half the
picture it's too strong what about my
harmonica
you saw the god of hammers hmm but if
you guys didn't know the Black Panther
world premiere is tonight the social
embargo is going to be up later tonight
so I'll be able to post a reaction
tomorrow I can't do a full review video
for a little while longer but I can do a
reaction so I'll try to do that Tuesday
morning there's a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
share the video using the tools on the
watch page congratulations to the winner
from my last spider-man video
Nero Wayne please private message me so
I can get your contact details click
here for a new black panther and click
here for a preview of the Shazam movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight
you